You've got the designer, the software engineer, and the product manager. And the short version of it is every single one of them doesn't think they need the other two now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like the software engineer thinks they can do both designing and product. But it's like, it's so true. Five or six or seven years ago when I was doing a lot more day-to-day engineering, I didn't know any of that stuff either. I don't think anyone ever did. If I needed to know how to use something, I would go and do some desperate Google search.
你拥有设计师、软件工程师和产品经理。简而言之，他们每个人现在都觉得不需要另外两个人了。没错，没错。就像软件工程师认为他们既能做设计也能做产品。但这确实是真的。五六七年前，当我做更多日常工程工作时，我也不懂这些。我觉得没人懂。如果我需要知道怎么用某个东西，我会去进行一番绝望的谷歌搜索。
Product managers and, like, team leads, they use. They used to just do what we are now doing. Like they would delegate to employees. And now we can delegate to these LLMs. And it is intoxicating. And I mean, I've kind of buried the lead. I forgot that I was supposed to tell you this. So very exciting personal news.
产品经理和团队负责人，他们过去只是做我们现在做的事情。比如他们会把工作委派给员工。而现在我们可以把工作委派给这些大语言模型（LLM）。这让人沉醉。我是不是有点本末倒置了？我忘了我应该告诉你这个。所以，有一个非常令人兴奋的个人消息。
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 278, recorded on March 10, 2020. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about living in the age of ideas. the ideas we have, whether AI is going to lead to cognitive atrophy, and also some exciting personal news. End of episode one, start of episode two. I hear people, like all these concerns. I listen to, I think it was a Hank Green.
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 278 期，录制于 2020 年 3 月 10 日。我是 Connor。今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊生活在创意时代。我们拥有的想法，人工智能是否会导致认知萎缩，以及一些令人兴奋的个人消息。第一集结束，第二集开始。我听到人们有各种各样的担忧。我听了，我想是 Hank Green 说的。
I don't know if you want to call it podcast, but it was him kind of monologuing for 75% of it, but then he talked to a professor for a little bit. Maybe those percentages are off. But there were all these concerns that he had, and like one of them was like cognitive atrophy. And the idea that, you know, because we're not thinking, quote unquote, as much, because of these tools, we, the same way you can have muscle atrophy, which is when, like, your muscles degrade when you're in outer space or because you're, like, bedridden in a hospital, or maybe degradation is the word. I mean, atrophy is the right word, but I'm just
我不知道你是否想称之为播客，但其中 75% 的时间是他自己在独白，然后他和一位教授聊了一会儿。也许这些比例不对。但他有各种担忧，其中之一就是认知萎缩。这种观点认为，因为我们不再像以前那样“思考”（所谓的思考），因为这些工具，我们就像肌肉萎缩一样——即当你身处外太空或因病卧床不起时，肌肉会退化，或者“退化”这个词更合适。我的意思是，萎缩是正确的词，但我只是
trying to find a word to explain it. But anyways, you don't use your muscles. They disappear. And so this is the same idea for your brain and I don't know I just I just I think that's kind of like wild that you think people are going to not be using their brain like you're going to use different
试图找一个词来解释它。但无论如何，你不使用肌肉，它们就会消失。所以大脑也是同样的道理。我不知道，我只是觉得，认为人们会不再使用大脑这种想法很疯狂，因为你会以不同的方式使用它。
because on one hand I do agree you do lose the ability like I always have this analogy of dictionaries like kids don't look things up in dictionaries anymore unless if you're like a great parent and you have a physical dictionary and you get your kids to look it up but I don't think most
因为一方面我确实同意你会失去某种能力。我总是用字典做类比，孩子们不再查字典了，除非你是一位伟大的父母，家里有实体字典，并让你的孩子去查。但我认为大多数
kids are using dictionaries these days. And you learn so much from looking things up in dictionaries, from the distribution of like letters. You know, like if you're looking up something that starts with a Z or Z or Z, if you're in America or a different country, you just go to the back and you start flipping the pages, right? Whereas if you are looking something up with an A, you still might flip a little bit. And like, where is F and P in relation to like the start and end? And then once you get close, you know, looking at the top left and right words. There's so much, like, you're basically doing a kind of binary search at a certain point. Kids don't do that now. You just, you know, go to type in the word and go define. And half these times, you just ask Alexa now or
孩子现在不使用字典了。通过查字典，你可以从字母的分布中学到很多东西。你知道，如果你要查一个以 Z 开头的词，如果你在美国或其他国家，你只需翻到后面开始翻页，对吧？而如果你查一个以 A 开头的词，你可能还是会翻一点。比如 F 和 P 在开头和结尾的什么位置？一旦你接近了，你就会看左上角和右上的词。这基本上是在进行某种二分查找。孩子们现在不这么做了。你只是输入单词然后点击定义。而且有一半时间，你现在只是问 Alexa 或者
Syria or whatever, like, AI, you know, or non-AI voice system that you have. And I do think that, like, that impacts the skills and the things that you learn. But do I think that, like, the youth are, like, doomed because they don't have dictionaries anymore? That's like, I don't know. It's, I don't know. Did you have thoughts? Like, have you heard of this, like, cognitive atrophy? Like, and people worrying that we're going to lose a generation of thinkers because we're,
Siri 或者其他什么，比如人工智能，或者你拥有的非人工智能语音系统。我确实认为这会影响技能和你学到的东西。但我认为年轻人因为不再使用字典就注定要失败吗？我不知道，我不知道。你有什么想法吗？你听说过这种“认知萎缩”吗？人们担心我们会失去一代思想家，因为我们
we're now, like, dispatching all of this, like, knowledge work. And the reason this came up is because I don't do the typing of, like, CD dot dot, you know, CD command. And then, like, I don't type. And a lot of the times now, like, now that I'm working with not Android Studio, but, like, the ADB shell commands in order to, like, build APKs and launch the emulator, I don't know how to spell any of that. stuff. I just know that the models know. I don't know about you, but like five or six or seven
现在正在把所有的知识工作都外包出去。之所以提到这个，是因为我不再输入像 `cd ..` 这样的命令了。我不再输入了。现在很多时候，既然我不是在用 Android Studio，而是在用 ADB shell 命令来构建 APK 并启动模拟器，我根本不知道怎么拼写那些东西。我只知道模型知道。我不知道你怎么样，但五六七
years ago when I was doing a lot more day-to-day engineering, I didn't know any of that stuff either. I don't think anyone ever did. If I needed to know how to use something, I would go and do some desperate Google search and then go look on some stackover floor or some other forum to find some magical invocation that would do what I wanted. I never, like there were some things that, like, I knew, but then there were also like a lot of things where I would have to go do the research myself on how to use the command or the tool or I would forget how to do something, I'd forget how to spell some flag
年前，当我做更多日常工程工作时，我也不懂这些。我觉得没人懂。如果我需要知道怎么用某个东西，我会去进行一番绝望的谷歌搜索，然后去 Stack Overflow 或其他论坛寻找能实现我想要功能的魔法指令。我从来没有……虽然有些东西我是知道的，但也有很多东西我必须自己去研究怎么使用那个命令或工具，或者我会忘记怎么做，忘记某个标志怎么拼写，
or something, or I would go like, you know, I would use the tool, but then I would do like dash-dash help and then like, you know, the help was not always like, you know, not always good. And like this is like true not just for like command line tools, but just like for like anything. Like, you know, I feel like it's just like more efficient now.
或者我会去使用那个工具，然后输入 `--help`，但帮助信息并不总是很好。这不仅适用于命令行工具，也适用于任何东西。我觉得现在只是效率更高了。
I don't buy that there's like a cognitive dissonance here. One, because we're still looking at a lot of code. I mean, at least me, I'm, I, you know, go and review the code. There's not, like, I don't review everything. If it's like a substantive change to like an API or something, like, yeah, I'm going to like review every line. If it's like, I've like written some script, you know, like, hey, like, you know, add a script to, you know, check the format of these Jupyter notebooks in this repo. I'm not going to go read that script because like I don't need to go and
我不认为这里存在认知失调。第一，因为我们仍然在看大量的代码。至少对我来说，我会去审查代码。并不是说我审查所有内容。如果这是对 API 或类似东西的实质性更改，是的，我会审查每一行。如果是我写的一些脚本，比如“嘿，添加一个脚本来检查这个仓库中 Jupyter Notebook 的格式”，我不会去读那个脚本，因为我不需要去
understand all the details of that little script. That's like not load bearing. You know, that's like something that's going to run is like a GitHub action. What I need to know is whether that script is like doing the right job or not. And so like I'll like write the tests for it. I'll write the validation for it. But I don't necessarily need to read every line of that little Python code. Whereas like if I'm making a change to like my tutorial content or to like an API and like a critical library. Like, yeah, I'm going to read that a lot more carefully. But, like, I do feel like we're reading a lot more code. There are still, there are still times where I'm writing code, too, because one technique that I often use is if I know I need to make, like, a repetitive change
理解那个小脚本的所有细节。那不是核心部分。那只是作为 GitHub Action 运行的东西。我需要知道的是那个脚本是否在做正确的工作。所以我为它编写测试，为它编写验证。但我并不一定需要阅读那段 Python 代码的每一行。然而，如果我是在修改我的教程内容或关键库中的 API，是的，我会更仔细地阅读。但我确实觉得我们阅读的代码更多了。仍然有我编写代码的时候，因为我经常使用的一种技巧是，如果我知道我需要在代码库的多个地方进行重复更改，并且我知道该更改的具体样子，或者即使我知道我需要进行类似的更改，我也会手动输入我想要的更改。然后我会高亮
in a bunch of places in the code base, and if I know exactly what that change will look like, or even if, like, I know, like, I need to make, like, a similar change, I will go and manually type the change I want. And then I'll highlight. that context, I'll put it into the chat and I'll say, hey, go like, you know, I want, for example, yesterday I was changing some of the imports, like the ordering of the imports in some of my Python notebooks. And I wanted it, like, formatted like in a certain way and in a certain order. And so I went and I did it in the way that I wanted. And then I highlighted it and I told the agent, like, here's how I want it. Go like description of the change. Go order things this way.
那个上下文，把它放进聊天框里说：“嘿，比如，我想要……”例如，昨天我正在更改一些导入，比如我的一些 Python Notebook 中导入的顺序。我希望它以某种方式和某种顺序格式化。所以我按照我想要的方式做了一次。然后我高亮显示它并告诉代理：“这是我想要的。去……（描述更改）……按这种方式排序。”
here's an example that I just did for you, go apply it everywhere else. And like that was a lot quicker than me because that was on the third try where I had started it off on this task, which was like to change how one thing was imported. And the first time it had done the change correctly, but I did not like how the code was structured. And so I asked it to change it. And I described how I wanted it changed. And then it didn't get it quite right the second time.
“这是我刚为你做的例子，去把它应用到其他所有地方。”这比我自己做快多了，因为那是在我第三次尝试时才完成的，我最初开始这项任务时，是要更改一个东西的导入方式。第一次它正确地完成了更改，但我不太喜欢代码的结构。所以我要求它更改。我描述了我希望它如何更改。然后第二次它做得不太对。
And then the third time I was about to describe for it again how I wanted it to be changed. And I was like, you know what? I'm just going to give it the example. And I found myself doing that a lot of like giving an example or a pattern to follow or like pseudocode or something. So I definitely, I think at least for me who was in more of like an engineering leadership role and was maybe prior to last year, I was only spending like 30 or 40% of my time writing code, whereas I feel like I'm spending more time now doing. software engineering work, not necessarily writing code, but driving the writing of code. I feel like that means my skills are not atrophied, but I'm actually using them more than I would have otherwise.
然后第三次我正要再次描述我希望它如何更改时，我想：“你知道吗？我直接给它例子吧。”我发现自己经常这样做，提供一个例子、一个要遵循的模式、伪代码之类的。所以我绝对认为，至少对我来说，处于工程领导角色，可能在去年之前，我只有 30% 或 40% 的时间在写代码，而现在我觉得我花更多时间在做软件工程工作，不一定是写代码，而是驱动代码的编写。我觉得这意味着我的技能没有萎缩，反而比以前用得更多了。
Yeah, there's this anecdote that I've heard a couple times on a different podcast where, like, you've got the designer, the software engineer, and the product manager, and every, like, the short version of it is every single one of them doesn't think they need the other two now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like the software engineer thinks they can do both designing and product. it's like, it's so true. Like, I, you know, it's basically, you know, product managers and like team leads. They used to just do what we are now doing. Like, they would delegate to employees. And now we can delegate to these LLMs. And it is, it is intoxicating. And like, I was never good at,
是的，我在另一个播客上听到过几次这个轶事：你拥有设计师、软件工程师和产品经理，简而言之，他们每个人现在都觉得不需要另外两个人了。没错，没错。就像软件工程师认为他们既能做设计也能做产品。这确实是真的。就像，你知道，基本上，产品经理和团队负责人，他们过去只是做我们现在做的事情。他们会把工作委派给员工。而现在我们可以把工作委派给这些大语言模型。这让人沉醉。我从来都不擅长，
you know, I don't know, go learning some framework. You know, I had done a bunch of different projects. Like at one point, I wrote a, my Scrabble training program called Hookstar. And I wrote it using Python and Pi Arcade. And it was, it never really looked that beautiful. And there was a bunch of things I wanted to add to it. Like it functioned the way I wanted to function, but it is, is it a good piece of software? No. You know, but like if I had started, you know, today with, it would be like a hundred times better.
你知道，去学习某个框架。我做过很多不同的项目。有一次，我写了一个名为 Hookstar 的 Scrabble 训练程序。我用 Python 和 Py Arcade 写的。它看起来从来都不太漂亮。我有很多想添加的东西。它实现了我想要的功能，但它是一件好的软件作品吗？不是。但如果我今天开始做，它会好上一百倍。
It would look nicer, you know, it would probably be sitting somewhere in some Pi Pi thing because, you know, in order to bundle something up and package it and release it, like, I'd be like, sure, well, why not do it, right? And yeah, it is, yeah, this idea that, I don't know, maybe for some folks, for some folks that aren't curious that don't want to learn or whatever, maybe this is like an easy way to just call it in every day. But now I'm just like every single thing that I've ever thought of as like an idea I can now go and implement. And I guess, yeah, maybe this is the time to pivot to the idea guy. The, my buddy just mentioned me, sent me a link the other day of the chief imagination officer at some company. and he was like they finally have created a C-level title for vibe coders.
它会看起来更好，它可能会放在某个 PyPI 之类的东西上，因为为了打包、封装并发布它，我会想：“当然，为什么不呢？”是的，这种想法……我不知道，也许对某些人来说，对那些不好奇、不想学习的人来说，这可能是一种每天敷衍了事的方法。但现在我只是觉得，我曾经想到的每一个想法，我现在都可以去实现它。我想，也许现在是转向“点子大王”的时候了。我的一个哥们前几天给我发了一个链接，是某家公司的“首席想象官”，他说他们终于为“氛围程序员”（vibe coders）创造了一个 C 级头衔。
I think we should start with the great Michael Garland quote that you gave, which is, yeah, that I'll, he's your boss, I'll let you say. Insights are ideas worth keeping. But the larger context was I was saying, I got all these ideas, you know, code doesn't even matter anymore. Like we need to put these ideas, you know, in papers or out in the world. But like the actual implementation, like everyone, like, and that's, yeah, anyway. So it's just the ideas slash insights. This is like the important stuff.
我想我们应该从你给出的伟大的 Michael Garland 名言开始，即……他是你的老板，我让你来说。“洞察力是值得保留的想法。”但更大的背景是我在说，我有所有这些想法，代码甚至都不重要了。我们需要把这些想法写在论文里或发布到世界上。但实际的实现，每个人……总之，重要的就是想法和洞察力。
And like that's why I'm so excited about this podcast player because like I was mentioning in the two episodes ago, I don't know anybody that listens to as many podcasts or spends as much time editing. And that that means that like just myself is probably better than like a team of 10 testers because every day I'm either in the car driving somewhere testing on Android Auto or you know, on a run or doing dishes or baking. And like every single time you're doing. that like you're running into different use cases of how you want this player to work.
这就是为什么我对这个播客播放器如此兴奋，因为正如我在两集前提到的，我不认识任何像我一样听这么多播客或花这么多时间剪辑的人。这意味着我一个人可能比 10 个测试人员的团队还要好，因为我每天要么在车里开车去某处，在 Android Auto 上测试，要么在跑步、洗碗或烘焙。每次你做这些事情时，你都会遇到关于你希望这个播放器如何工作的不同用例。
And I've got so many good ideas of like, I used to tweet out these like quotes and I would just make them in PowerPoint. And then I'd screenshot it and I'd tweet it out on Twitter. And it would be like a quote by, you know, Brian Cantrell from Oxide and Friends about about something. And wouldn't it be nice if during while you were listening to a podcast, you could just like hit pause right at the end of like what someone said, like hit some button that brings you to a dialogue where you can drag back a slider to where you want like the quote to start and end, then hit another button. It just turns that into a visual sound bite with like, you know, the podcast art, a little wavy
我有很多好点子，比如我过去常在 PowerPoint 里制作这些引语，然后截图发到 Twitter 上。那可能是 Brian Cantrell 在《Oxide and Friends》里说的关于某件事的引语。如果当你听播客时，能在某人说完话的瞬间按下暂停，点击某个按钮进入一个对话框，让你拖动滑块到你想要的引语开始和结束的位置，然后点击另一个按钮，把它变成一个带有播客封面、一个小波浪线……
thing that, you know, like every single time I send them out on Fridays. And then also to like, you know, transcribe the quote and then automatically put that as the content of like the tweet. And then like automatically do it to blue sky, Twitter, you know, all the different socials. That I guarantee you. You can do that in an afternoon. And I just am not at the point where I want to add like sharing functionality to the podcast player.
……的东西，那该多好。你知道，我每周五都会发这些东西。然后还要转录引语，并自动将其作为推文的内容。然后自动发布到 Blue Sky、Twitter，所有不同的社交平台。我敢保证，你一下午就能做到。但我现在还不想给播客播放器添加分享功能。
But, but yeah, like, ideas like that, I got, I got 100 ideas. And that's a great idea, folks, because you know what? That's a flywheel idea. You start getting people to post little clips. It highlights, you know, the great podcasts that are worth listening to for other people that are interested in finding podcast content. But at the same time, it'll say, listen to on Podgod. And then it'll get people interested in the podcast app.
但确实，像这样的点子，我有 100 个。那是个很棒的点子，伙计们，因为你知道吗？那是一个飞轮效应。你开始让人们发布小片段。它突出了值得其他人收听的优秀播客。但同时，它会说“在 Podgod 上收听”。这会让人们对这个播客应用感兴趣。
Anyways, what are your thoughts? What are your ideas, your grand envisions for the world? Well, so it's interesting because, like, I feel like you. have all of these like consumer facing ideas and like my ideas of like all like like either like work or just like very like system softwarey maybe that says something about like the type of person we are well you don't really listen to podcast right like I spend so much time listening to podcasts that I just like I realize that like all the podcast players suck they suck there's ads everywhere and so maybe if you know I don't know you like a lot there are
总之，你有什么想法？你对世界的宏伟构想是什么？嗯，这很有趣，因为我觉得你拥有所有这些面向消费者的想法，而我的想法要么是关于工作，要么是非常系统软件层面的。也许这说明了我们是哪种人。好吧，你其实不怎么听播客，对吧？我花这么多时间听播客，以至于我意识到所有的播客播放器都很烂，到处都是广告。所以也许，如果你……我不知道，你激励了我，有些事情是这样的，我一直在寻找好的软件来跟踪我的投资。我试过几个，没有一个真正能做到我想要的。我想，我可能可以自己构建一个完全符合我需求的东西。但很多我需要构建的东西，我只需要让 AI 为我构建……我不需要为此开发一个应用。我不需要为此构建软件。我可以直接用 AI 来完成任务。
some things, like, you have, like, inspired me that there were some things where it's like, you know, like, I don't have like a, you know, I've been searching for like a good software to, like, track, track my, like, investments. Like, I've tried a couple and, like, none of them really do what I want. It's like, oh, I could probably just, like, build something that does exactly what I want. But, like, a lot of the things that I've, that I need to build are things where I can just have an AI, build me the, like, I don't need, like, an app for it. Like, I don't, I don't need to build software for it. I can just use AI to, like, do the task.
比如，投资的事情就是一个很好的例子。我可以构建一个单独的应用或软件来跟踪我的投资。或者我可以告诉它：“给我建一个电子表格。”如果我告诉它给我建一个电子表格，Excel 可能拥有我需要的所有功能，这作为平台可能就足够了。或者，如果我需要……我倾向于给 AI 的很多任务是生成某种已知格式的文档。播客那个点子真的很棒，因为它是一个具体的东西，它不是一种已知格式的东西。它不像你需要 Excel 电子表格来听播客。你只是对现有的播客播放器感到沮丧。但你还有所有这些其他项目，比如各种 Web 前端的东西，像 Array Box，或者你总是同时在构建十几个这样的项目，甚至在 AI 出现之前你就这么做了。
Like, you know, like, the investment thing is like a good example. Like, I could build, like, a separate, like, app or a piece of software for, like, you know, tracking my investments. Or I could just tell it, like, build me a spreadsheet. And the, if I tell it to just, like, build me a spreadsheet, like, Excel probably has all the functionality to do what I need. And, like, that's probably fine as a platform for it. Or, like, if I need, like, a lot of the tasks that I tend to give AI are, like,
我不知道。我想也许我有很多这样的东西。有一件事我确实希望我能用 AI 来做，但我还没能做到，那就是构建我的幻灯片，因为我在 PowerPoint 中有我现有的全部幻灯片库。我对视觉效果以及我希望幻灯片视觉效果呈现的方式非常挑剔。我发现 AI 仍然在生成我想要的象形图或幻灯片图形方面非常吃力。这对我来说仍然是一个严重的痛点。我知道我这周得花时间为下周英伟达的会议 GTC 制作幻灯片。我知道那将是一件非常耗时的事情。我希望我有能帮我做这个的 AI。所以是的，让我们列举一下。有些东西我甚至都没提，我最新的创作是我的 AI 训练配速，用于我的跑步目标。哦，也许现在是个好时机。我有点本末倒置了。我忘了我应该告诉你这个。所以，非常令人兴奋的个人消息。太随机了。它会出现在第 269 集的中间。
like generating some form of known, some form of document in like a known format. And like the podcast one was like a really good idea because like that it's like a concrete thing that like it's not like a known format of thing. It's not like you need like it's not like there's an Excel spreadsheet equivalent for listening to podcasts. It's like you're frustrated with the podcasts at players that exist out there. But then like you also you have all these other projects of like these various like sort of web front-end things like the array box or like you always have like a dozen of these that you're
我可能应该把它放在开头。Shea 和我有一个非常令人兴奋的消息要与 Bryce 和 ADSP 社区分享。我们要有宝宝了。哦，恭喜。你知道是男孩还是女孩吗？我们知道。我们做了一个基因测试，测试健康状况。我相信 Shima 作为医生会比我解释得好得多。但关键是，所有进行基因测试的项目风险都很低。而且其中一部分也包含了性别。所以我们要生个男孩。哦，恭喜。太棒了，伙计。我真为你感到高兴。哇。你可能在想，为什么我们一直在聊 AI，聊了一个小时。
building at any given point in time and you did this even before AI. I don't know. I guess maybe I have lots of those things. One thing that I could, that I do wish I could use AI for but I've not really been able to yet is for building my slide decks because like I have my entire library of existing slides in PowerPoint. I'm very specific about the visuals and how I want the visuals of my slides to appear. And the thing that I've still find AI struggles substantially with is generating me like pictographs or like graphics for slides that look exactly like what I want. And that remains like a, that remains a serious pinpoint for me. And like that, like I know I have to spend some time this week making slides for Nvidia's conference next week, GTC. And I know that that's going to be like
然后 Connor 突然想起他要有个儿子了。这就是我创建 AI 训练配速的原因，我让它给自己起个名字，因为我正试图在宝宝出生前完成最后一场马拉松并跑进 2 小时 30 分。最后一场马拉松？以后不会再有马拉松了。是的，是的。好吧，首先，我讨厌马拉松。它们太糟糕了。去听听我的另一个播客 R4，听我抱怨它们有多糟糕。但这太搞笑了，因为我创建了这个 AI 训练器。
a huge time consuming thing. And I wish I had AI that could help me with that. So yes, let's let's enumerate. I mean, there's stuff that I don't even talk about that my newest creation is my AI trainer pace for my running goals. Oh, and maybe this is a good time. I mean, I've kind of buried the lead. I forgot that I was supposed to tell you this. So, very exciting personal news. It's so random. It's going to be in the middle of like episode 269.
我非常密切地跟踪我的饮食和体重。所以我给了它五年的体重数据和一年的饮食数据。然后说：“帮我制定一个实现这些目标的方案。”在它进行了一番计算后，它说：“好消息，你有好消息也有坏消息。好消息是你跑得很快。坏消息是你的饮食糟透了。”它最经典的一句是：“你是一个 2 小时 42 分的马拉松选手，吃得却像个在义卖会上吃东西的大学生。”
Probably should have put this at the beginning. Shea and I have very exciting news to share with Bryce and the ADSP community. We will be expecting a baby. Oh, congratulations. Do you know if it's a boy or girl yet? We do know. We got a genetic test that test for healthiness things. I'm sure Shima would, as a doctor, have explained that a lot better than I did. But the key thing is, is that all of the things it was tested for genetically were very low risk. And also a part of that comes the gender. So we are having a baby boy. Oh, congratulations. That's awesome, man. I'm so excited for you. Wow. And you're probably thinking, why was it, we were talking about AI for like an hour straight.
我告诉了 Shima，她觉得太搞笑了。总之，多亏了我的 AI 训练配速，我现在吃得健康多了。但是的，我们将尝试做很多事情，因为宝宝出生后，我做 AI 相关事情的空闲时间会变少。总之，我们有 AI 训练器。我们有提到的 Array Box。我们有 Podgod，那个播放器和编辑器。我有一个金融仪表盘，是我在 Claude 3.5 时代构建的，经常放在我的一个显示器上。它跟踪英伟达的价格、美元兑加元的价格，以及我所有其他类别的资产，比如 RSP 等等。
And then all of a sudden, Connor remembered that he's having a son is that the reason I created my AI trainer Pace, I asked him to give himself a name, is because I am trying to run a final marathon and break 2.30 before the baby comes. A final marathon. There will be no marathons. Yeah, yeah. Well, first of all, I hate marathons. They're awful. Go listen to R4 my other podcast and listen to me whine about how bad they are. But it's so funny because I created this AI trainer.
因为我想有一天，加拿大有一家叫 Wealth Simple 的公司，我认为它大致相当于 Robin Hood，你可以把所有的现金、股票等等放在一个账户里，然后它会给你显示一个汇总仪表盘。但我不是 Wealth Simple 的用户，我也不想换。所以我当时想，我敢打赌我可以自己构建一个汇总仪表盘，我也确实这么做了。所以我们有 AI 训练器。我们有 Array Box。我们应该聊聊 Array Box，因为多亏了你，我得以改进它。这就是重点，甚至不是我想到的点子。
I track my diet pretty closely and also my weight. And so I gave it like five years worth of weight data and a year's worth of diet data. And then was like, build me a thing to break these goals. And then after it did like a bunch of churning, it's like great news. You got good news and bad news. Good news is it's like you're very fast. The bad news is that your diet is atrocious. Its main line was you're a 242 marathoner eating like a university student at a bake sale.
你指出了某一点。然后我当时想：“哦，是的，那是个好点子。我怎么没想到？”果然，几个小时后，它就实现并完成了。还有我希望去写的书。现在的问题是我手头有太多事情在做。书的进度有点停滞了。我创建了标题页，然后就那样了。
And I told Shima that and she thought it was so funny. Anyway, so I'm eating a lot healthier now thanks to my AI trainer pace. But yes, we're going to be trying to do a lot because I will be having less free time to do all my AI stuff once the baby comes. Anyways, we got the AI trainer. We've got array box that we mentioned. We got Podgod, the player and also the editor. I have a financial dashboard that I built back in like the Claude 3.5 days that sits on one of my monitors pretty regularly. It tracks like the price of invidia, the price of the U.S. Canadian dollar, and then like all my different other classes of whatever things like RSP, etc.
还有，Array Box 后面有仪表盘，显示人们更频繁地使用哪些语言。总之，现在我需要更多。我有四个显示器。我需要更多……我应该买六个显示器的，因为我的四个显示器中有三个专门用于仪表盘，它们只是持续显示在那里。你会问：“你需要一直盯着 Wiiwa、APL 和 BQN 的小刻度吗？”比如，我有一个小折线图，显示当有人提交 BQN 命令与 Tiny Apple 命令时，这给我带来了巨大的快乐。你无法想象，看到人们使用你构建的东西是多么令人高兴。
Because I thought one day there's a company in Canada called Wealth Simple, which I think loosely is the equivalent of Robin Hood, which like you can kind of have all your your cash, your equity, blah, blah, blah. in like one account, and then it just shows you like a summary dashboard. I'm not with well simple, though, and I didn't really want to switch. And so I was like, I bet I could build my own like summary dashboard by myself, which I did. So we've got the AI trainer. We got a ray box. We should talk about a ray box because thanks to you, I was able to improve. And that's the thing is like it wasn't even me with the ideas.
甚至只是在手机上看到 Podgod 应用，每次我打开它，它都因为 10 个不同的原因给我带来巨大的快乐，因为第一，这是一个没有广告的应用。它就是我用过的最好的应用。第二，我构建了它。使用自己构建的东西真的很酷。并不是说我以前没构建过有用的东西，但像听播客和跑步这样如此核心的东西。
You pointed me, pointed something out. And then I was like, oh, yeah, that's a great idea. Why didn't I think of that? And then sure enough, like a couple hours later, it was implemented and done. Then there's the book that I'm hopefully going to. That's the problem now is I got so many things that I'm working on. The book is kind of stalled. I created the title page and then that was about it.
这两件事是我每周生活中很大的一部分。现在我提高了它们的质量，这对我来说意义重大。我不知道这对听众或你来说是否有意义。对我来说有意义。我的意思是，这确实很酷。我一直在自己使用它。
And then also, too, I've got dashboards behind array box that show like what languages people are using more frequently. Anyway, so now I need more. I've got four monitors. I need more than, I should have gotten six monitors because three of my four monitors are dedicated to dashboards that are just constantly there. And you're like, do you need to constantly look at like the Wiiwa and APL and BQN, a little like ticks, like, you know, I have a little line graph that shows when when someone submits a BQN command versus a tiny Apple command, it brings me so much joy. You have no idea, like, to see people using something that you've built.
是的，这真的很酷。我给 Ramona 展示了它。她说：“等等，这是 Connor 构建的？”是的，技术上是 Claude 4.6 构建的。我设计了它。但不可否认，你用的是个糟糕的版本。有很多修复。我可能已经给自己发布了大约 10 个更新的 APK 版本，因为最初，
And like, and like even just like seeing the Podgod app on my phone, like every time I open it, it brings me so much joy for like 10 different reasons because it's like one, it's an app that works with no ads. It's just like, it's the best app that I've used. And two, I built it. Like, it's so, it's so cool to use something like usefully. Not that I had never built anything useful before, but like something so integral, like, listening to podcasts and like running.
你那个版本最大的问题是，你如何标记某样东西为“已完成”并将其添加到历史记录中？如果你只听了播客的 2%，那应该算作“已听过”的播客吗？因为很多时候我会非常激进地跳过主题。有些播客我听。一个很好的例子是《The Daily》。我每周听五天，周一到周五。但我一点也不关心周六的采访。
Those are two things that are like such a big part of like my week. And now that I've improved like the quality of that, it's just such a, it's so meaningful for me. I don't know if that makes sense to listeners or to you. It makes sense to me. I mean, like, it is pretty cool. Like I have been using. I have been using it myself.
通常他们会有一些主题，也许六个里有一个我会周日听。所以通常我只是自动跳过那些。我只是删掉它们。所以那些显然不应该计入你听过的集数，但我确实希望它计入播客的总收听百分比。所以，在统计数据上，
And yeah, it's like pretty cool. Like, I showed it to Ramona. And she's like, wait, Connor built this. Yeah, well, technically Claude 4.6 built it. I designed it. But admittedly, you're using a bad version. Like, there's a ton of fic. I've released to myself probably like 10 newer versions of the APKs because initially, like,
你有听过的集数、总时间，还有百分比。那个百分比应该代表你听了该播客发布内容的百分之多少，无论你是否听完了那一集。因为我想知道，在一个月内，
the biggest issue with your version is that how do you mark something as like finished and then add it to the history? Like if you only listen to like 2% of a podcast, should that go as like a listen to podcast? Because a lot of times I very aggressively will skip topics. Like there's podcasts that I listen to. Like a great example is the daily. I listen to the daily five days a week, Monday to Friday. But I could care less for the interview on Saturday.
我把大部分时间都花在哪些播客上了？这实际上让我感到难过。ADSP 只有 30、40 分钟的集数让我感到难过，因为我们的收听时间太少了。现在我的目标是在未来发布我们的播客，正如他刚才提到的，他九月份要生儿子了。是的，Connor，你什么时候有时间做那个？好吧，我的目标是到九月份，Podgod 编辑器会有一个叫“安全编辑”的按钮，它会移除……它会截断静音，它会移除所有的“嗯”和“啊”。它不会很好地清理
And usually they have some topic that maybe one out of every six I'll listen to on Sunday. And so usually I just like auto skip those. Like I just remove them. So those don't clearly shouldn't count towards. the number of episodes you've listened to, but I do want it to count towards the total percentage listened to of the podcast. So, like, on the stats,
人们互相打断的情况，但至少把它收紧并去掉“嗯”声。虽然现在我得编辑这个，你可能听不到那些“嗯”声，除非我有足够的精力把它们留着，这样听众现在就不会困惑。但确实，我应该停止胡言乱语了。重点是，我应该有六个显示器，因为我有太多东西要构建了。我没有足够的屏幕来监控所有这些东西。是的，你看，我还是只用一个显示器。我从来没理解多显示器这回事。
you've got number of episodes listened to, total time, and then also percentage. And that percentage is supposed to represent what percentage of the content that this podcast puts out, regardless if you even started the episode, do you listen to? Because I want to know, like, over a month,
这太多了。我觉得对我来说太容易分心了，所以……你只用一个显示器？那太疯狂了，伙计。所以我的设置现在是，我不知道我有没有在这里说过，但是，我的很多人体工程学问题都因为两件事消失了。第一，我直接在床上工作。正如我告诉人们的那样，在工作中，我经常会……
what podcasts am I dedicating the most time to? And it actually makes me sad. It makes me sad that ADSP only has 30, you know, 40 minute episodes, because we're way down there on listening time. Now it is my goal to release our podcast in the future, as he just mentioned that he's having a son in September. Yeah. When are you going to have time to do that, Connor? Well, my goal is by September, the pod god editor is going to be like, is going to have a button called Safe Edit, which will remove the, it'll truncate silence, it will remove all the ums and Oz. It won't clean up very well
等等，你刚才说什么？我刚才看了看手机，因为我几分钟后有个快递。我说，我刚才听到……我的大脑在追赶你说的词。你刚才说你在床上工作？没错。好吧，不是在我的床上，是在第二张床上。你知道，我多年来一直有各种人体工程学问题，从我在伯克利实验室时就开始了，然后我在那里时稍微解决了一些，它们在英伟达时又持续存在。然后在疫情期间，很多问题消失了，但我工作得比以往任何时候都多。但在疫情期间，我在家工作。我在加州的公寓非常小，家里没有书桌，因为我坚信“政教分离”。不，你知道，我不居家办公。但一旦我开始居家办公，我需要一个地方工作，又订不到桌子。所以我只是在沙发上工作，我总是像这样……在沙发上，在笔记本电脑上打字。
speaking over one another, but at least getting like tightening it up and getting rid of the ums is going to be, although now I've got to edit this and probably you're not going to hear those ums, unless if I had enough wherewithal to keep those in so the list is not confused right now. But yeah, it's, yeah, I should stop Ramley. The point is, is I should have had six monitors because I got so much stuff that I'm building. I don't have enough screens to monitor all this stuff. Yeah, see, I'm still, I'm still just like on one monitor. I've never understood the multiple monitors things.
对于听众来说，Bryce 刚才演示了躺着，一只手臂撑着头。因为你显然通过音频录音中的沉默捕捉到了这一点。所以，当我们……我在纽约时继续有这些人体工程学问题。当我们住在第一个公寓时，你知道，我用的是那边的桌子。我试过每一种疯狂的键盘。你知道，我有那种垂直的键盘。我有分体式键盘，那种垂直的。我试过把它们安装在椅子上。
It's like too much. It's too many distractions for me, I think, would be the problem. So, so. You're on one monitor? That's a nuts, ma'am. So my setup right now, I don't know if I've talked about this here, but, you know, a lot of my ergonomic issues have gone away due to two things. One, I just worked from my bed. And as I've told people on, like, at work, like, I'll often have my.
我几乎试过所有东西。但我还是有问题。但后来在某个时候，我想我的椅子，我的办公椅……好吧，音频文件听众会认出 Bryce 旧的 Blue Yeti 的声音，因为我的 Rode 无线麦克风电池没电了。总之，恢复故事。所以当我们搬到新公寓时，我的办公椅有点快不行了。我上次在桌子前有适合我的人体工程学设置是在伯克利实验室的时候。那是特定品牌和型号的办公椅。
Wait, did you? I had checked my phone because I'm supposed to have a delivery in a couple of minutes. And I said, did I just hear, like, and so I was, my brain was catching up with the words you said. Did you just say you work from your bed? Correct. Well, not from my bed, from the second bed. And, you know, I had all these ergonomic issues for many years, like starting when I was at Berkeley Lab, and then I sort of fixed him when I was there, and they continued at Nvidia. And then during the pandemic, a lot of them went away, but I was working like more than ever. But during the pandemic, I was working from home. And my apartment in California, very small, did not have a desk at home because I was big believer in separation of church and state. No, you know, I don't work from home. But then once I started working from home, I needed someplace to work from, couldn't order a desk. So I just worked from my couch and I would always be like, you know, like this on my couch, typing on my laptop.
当我去英伟达时，我找到了同一款办公椅。这很棘手，因为他们基本上不卖给消费者。我不得不从一个主要只卖给公司的研究卖家那里买，我不得不开车去加州荒郊野外去取。总之，我用这把办公椅很长时间了，座垫都磨损了。我最新的进化版是在桌子前打字的方式是，把那个托盘放在膝盖上，然后键盘放在托盘上。但托盘有点重。所以也许那是问题的一部分。但长话短说，如果我坐在那把椅子上
And for the listener, Bryce just like demonstrated lying down with one arm like holding his head up. Because clearly you caught that by the silence that was there on the audio recording. But so, so when we, I continued having ergonomic issues in New York. And when we were in our first apartment, you know, I was using this desk over there. And I've tried, like, every crazy keyboard. You know, I had the keyboards that, like, went vertical. Like, I had the split keyboards, the ones that go, like, vertical. I tried mounting them to my chair.
太久，就不舒服了。那个设置不舒服。所以我开始，你知道，只是在第二个卧室的床上放松，就在我桌子旁边。我开始越来越多地那样做。我开始注意到我的很多人体工程学问题都消失了。我认为很大一部分原因是，他们说对人体工程学最好的事情就是经常变换姿势。如果我在椅子上，如果我坐在桌子前，我基本上不会那么频繁地变换姿势。而且我倾向于向前倾，而如果我在床上，我会在坐直、盘腿、伸腿坐直之间轮换，然后侧卧，或者换另一侧，然后是一些其他疯狂的姿势。
I tried pretty much everything. And I continued to having issues. But then at some point, I guess my chair, my office chair. Okay, audio file listeners will recognize the sound of Bryce's old blue Yeti because my little road wireless microphones battery died. Anyways, so resuming the story. So when we moved to our new apartment, my desk chair was sort of on its last leg. And the last time I had an ergonomic setup that worked for me at a desk was when I was at Berklee Lab. And it was with the specific, like, making model of desk chair.
我几乎尝试了所有方法，但问题依然存在。后来有段时间，我猜是我的椅子，我的办公椅出了问题。好吧，音频听众会认出这是Bryce那台旧蓝色Yeti麦克风的声音，因为我的罗德无线麦克风没电了。总之，回到故事。当我们搬到新公寓时，我的办公椅已经快报废了。我上一次拥有适合我的办公桌人体工学设置是在伯克利实验室的时候，当时用的就是那款特定型号的办公椅。
And when I went to Nvidia, I, like, sourced the same desk chair. And it was tricky because they basically don't sell them to consumers. I had to, like, buy it from, like, a, like, a research. seller who sells mainly just to companies and I had to drive to like the middle of nowhere in California to pick it up. Anyways, I've had this desk chair for a long time and like the seed is like worn out and the way that I, like my latest evolution of how I was typing at a desk was that tray that would go on my knees and then the keyboard would go on that tray. But like the tray was a little bit heavy. So maybe that was part of the issue. But long story short, if I sat in that chair
当我去了英伟达，我设法找到了同一款办公椅。这很棘手，因为他们基本上不向消费者出售这种椅子。我不得不从一家主要向公司销售的经销商那里购买，而且我还得开车去加州一个偏僻的地方去取。总之，我用这把椅子很久了，坐垫已经磨损了。我最近打字方式的演变是使用一个放在膝盖上的托盘，然后把键盘放在托盘上。但那个托盘有点重，所以这可能也是问题的一部分。但长话短说，如果我坐在那把椅子上
for too long, it was not comfortable. The setup was not comfortable. So I would start, you know, just like chilling on the bed that's in our second bedroom that's right next to where my desk is. And I just started doing that more and more. And I started noticing that a lot of my ergonomic issues were going away. And I think that a large part of it is that they say that like the best thing for you for your like ergonomics is to be, is to change positions a lot. And if I'm on the chair, if I'm like sitting at a desk, I'm basically not changing positions that frequently. and I tend to lean forward a lot, whereas if I'm on the bed, I will rotate between sitting up, cross-legged, sitting up with my legs out, and then lying on one side versus lying on the other side and then like some other like crazy positions.
坐太久的话，就会很不舒服。整个设置都不舒服。所以我开始在我们的第二间卧室的床上放松，那间卧室就在我办公桌旁边。我开始越来越多地这样做，然后我注意到我的许多人体工学问题都消失了。我认为很大一部分原因是，人们常说对人体工学最好的做法是经常变换姿势。如果我坐在椅子上，坐在办公桌前，我基本上不会频繁变换姿势，而且我倾向于经常前倾。而如果我在床上，我会在坐着、盘腿坐、伸腿坐、侧卧、换另一侧侧卧以及其他一些奇怪的姿势之间切换。
And so I was telling some of my coworkers this when I was visiting at the office in January. And I told them like, yeah, like that's why I have my camera off a lot during meetings because if I'm lying on my side like this looking like a, you know, a cover model for some magazine. You know, I don't think that's the most professional look. So I leave the camera off. But anyways, yeah, between that and the fact that I'm not typing as much as I used to or typing in different ways than I used to. My work set up right now is I work from the laptop on the bed. And I do have technically a second monitor, which is my iPad. And the way I use it is that if I'm calling into a meeting where I have to, like, be taking notes,
所以我一月份去办公室的时候跟一些同事说了这件事。我告诉他们，这就是为什么我在开会时经常关掉摄像头的原因，因为如果我像这样侧躺着，看起来就像某本杂志的封面模特一样。你知道，我觉得那看起来不太专业。所以我把摄像头关了。但不管怎样，除了这一点，还有我打字不像以前那么多了，或者说打字的方式和以前不一样了。我现在的工作环境是在床上用笔记本电脑工作。我技术上确实有一个第二显示器，就是我的iPad。我使用它的方式是，如果我参加一个需要做笔记的会议，
I'll have the iPad join the meeting so that I can look at whatever somebody's screen sharing with me while I take the notes on the laptop. But that is the only second screen that I really use right now. For the most part, I work solely from this laptop, which is still a special Lenovo anniversary edition 25 from like eight to nine years ago. I've been waiting a while to upgrade my laptop, but we'll probably do so soon. That is wild. Wow. I don't know how you can do it. I mean, it's fine for a week if you're on site somewhere at a conference.
我会让iPad加入会议，这样我就可以在笔记本电脑上做笔记的同时，查看别人共享给我的屏幕。但那是目前我真正使用的唯一第二屏幕。在大多数情况下，我完全只用这台笔记本电脑工作，它仍然是八九年前那款特别的联想25周年纪念版。我等升级笔记本电脑已经有一段时间了，但可能很快就会升级。这太疯狂了。哇。我不知道你是怎么做到的。我的意思是，如果你在某个地方参加会议，用一周还可以。
But especially with Cursor and the fact that usually I want like a dedicated monitor for Cursor. And also too, like I picked up the fourth monitor and it's a 32 inch monitor. And that one is really nice because you really want more real estate for Cursor because you've got your, you know, the 5. folder view on the left, you've got your code in the middle, and then you've got your agent panel on the right. And a lot of times you want, you know, you got to be watching what the trace is doing. You still want to see the code. And just, I don't know, whatever, I'm probably, it's a privileged position to have so much real estate for my cursor window. But then also, too, like a lot of the stuff that I'm doing, whether it's websites or dashboards, or even, you know,
但特别是考虑到Cursor，通常我想要一个专门的显示器给Cursor用。而且，我还买了一个第四显示器，是一个32英寸的显示器。那个显示器真的很好，因为你确实需要更多的空间给Cursor，因为你有左侧的文件夹视图，中间的代码，还有右侧的代理面板。很多时候你需要观察追踪器在做什么。你仍然想看到代码。而且，我不知道，随便吧，能有这么大的空间给我的Cursor窗口可能是一种特权。但同时，我做的很多事情，无论是网站还是仪表盘，甚至，你知道，
like, I have a kernel profiling tool. Like, that's a work thing. I don't want that, like, hiding the cursor window. I want that on one of my other monitors. But I guess everyone's got their different workflow. If a single screen on a laptop in bed works for you, who am I to judge? Yeah. Yeah, I mean, I don't know. It's been working for me. I can't complain. And you know, like, if the setup works, I'm just going to keep doing it. And maybe I could go back to the desk. But I'm very happy with my current arrangement. I suspect I could go back to the desk. I suspect that it's just the, the, the, The AI is the big change in my ergonomics more than anything else. Yeah, yeah.
比如，我有一个内核分析工具。那是工作用的。我不希望它遮挡住Cursor窗口。我希望它在我的其他显示器上。但我想每个人的工作流程都不同。如果躺在床上用笔记本电脑的单屏工作适合你，我有什么资格评判呢？是啊。是啊，我的意思是，我不知道。它一直很适合我。我没什么可抱怨的。你知道，如果这个设置有效，我就继续用它。也许我可以回到书桌前。但我对目前的安排非常满意。我怀疑我可以回到书桌前。我怀疑AI对我的工作人体工程学的影响比其他任何东西都大。是啊，是啊。
I was going to say, comment in the GitHub discussion, folks, if you also work from bed. I'm guessing the number of folks out there that have four monitors is much higher than the number of folks that work from bed on like a full-time basis. I think so. But be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a link to a link to a podcast. get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我正想说，如果你们也躺在床上工作，请在GitHub讨论区留言。我猜拥有四个显示器的人数远多于全职躺在床上工作的人数。我想也是。但请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSP thepodcast.com上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及指向GitHub讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。我们的口号是充满信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。